une autre de bataille dès aujourd'hui en
pensant chaque jour à toutes celles et
tous ceux qui croient en eux qui ont
besoin de nous c'est un groupe politique
qui se définit comme étant la première
force d'opposition au françois
en 2014 la participation de samuel
tavernier le leader d'initiative
franciscaine était une première aux
élections municipales 40% des voix
obtenues au second tour pour les
élections municipales de 2001 le
candidat du mouvement initiative
franciscaine mise sur l'ouverture
autrement dit le rassemblement ce
rassemblement plus large plus larges que
ceux qui étaient auparavant
et aujourd'hui nous accueillons guerre
les gens qui étaient dans les listes de
droite
auparavant aux municipales nous
accueillons également des personnes qui
étaient sur la liste des patriotes
franciscaine lors des dernières
municipales de contrebande et nous avons
élargi le panel et les franciscains
seront heureux de savoir effectivement
aujourd'hui à une opposition très forte
qui viennent défendre les couleurs des
franciscains lors de cette rentrée
politique samuel tavernier a détaillé
ses futurs chantiers comme par exemple
la protection des franciscains et la
défense de leurs intérêts le cadre de
vie des riverains ou encore la mise en
place d'une démocratie participative
démarche participative ça veut dire que
interroger la population lorsque
effective mais à des choix qui la
concerne qui vont être faits et puis
deuxièmement un bien venir leur donner
le résultat
en leur disant voilà vous nous avez
confié mandat bien on vient vous rendre
compte
pensez que c'est facile à mettre en
place c'est pas facile mais il faut il
faut y aller faire de l'éducation une
priorité protéger les petits commerces
dynamiser le bourg du françois
les projets du candidat aux élections
municipales sont nombreux reste
maintenant à samuel tavernier leader du
mouvement initiative franciscaine de
constituer son équipe